our minds have made an error
we look at these gliding beauties of
marvelous complexity and we think that
they and we are something of our own
that life is a kind of indescribable
magic even Darwin said in his gorgeous
conclusion to on the Origin of Species
that life was something that had been
quote originally breathed into a few
forms or into one this completely
understandable perspective is
nonetheless an error there was no way
for Darwin to know it but life life is
chemistry from diatom to Diana life is
not a magical imbued trait it is a
process of the physics of our universe
the precise and convoluted chemistry of
life requires specific physical and
chemical situations and this planet has
a dizzying variety of such circumstances
that over millions or even billions of
years living chemical systems have
evolved to thrive in but one thing that
is always necessary is energy a system
without energy doesn't just not have
life it doesn't have chemistry and so
the story of life is the story of
captured energy
[Music]
these are a Silla Toria a form of
cyanobacteria every second of every day
for billions of years the Sun has been
exploding sending energy to the earth in
the form of sunlight and on the other
end or really on our end our
photosynthetic bacteria like these that
use the energy of that light to
construct chemical complexity these
asila Toria are gliding toward that
light so that they can harvest the
energy they need to produce a kind of
chemical so powerful so important that
you will probably be surprised to find
out that it's just sugar though sugar
such a chemical marvel just carbon and
hydrogen and oxygen but an evolutionary
innovation so fundamental that it
remains a primary source of nourishment
for even the most advanced living things
you may have seen this beautiful
filamentous algae called spirogyra
floating on the surface of water where
it also takes advantage of sunlight to
produce its own food a silla Toria in
spirogyra our autotrophs Otto for self
troph for nourishment in the world of
ecology we call these self nourishes the
primary producers they are where it all
begins
primary producers can turn the
fundamental inorganic components of
their surrounding environment into food
in the case of photosynthetic or
phototrophic organisms the energy
component of that surrounding
environment is light there are also
physical components they need carbon
dioxide and water and nitrogen and
phosphorus for building materials but
light is
the energy this is the first way
organisms get food they make it and most
autotrophs use light but not all there
are also lithotripsy for example that
use chemical bonds in minerals to thrive
unfortunately we don't have any footage
of them so just more spirogyra for you
[Music]
and like plants in our macroscopic
systems autotrophic microbes are the
starting point of the story of captured
energy because in their bid to hold on
to and use that energy they themselves
become balls of stored energy not just
in their energy storage systems like
their sugars but their whole selves are
bags of entropically unstable complexity
ready to fall into randomness the moment
their chemistry fails I think we have to
understand here that randomness is the
natural state of the universe
not because of some inherent evil but
just because there are literal trillions
of random ways for atoms and molecules
to be scattered about and a vanishingly
small number of ways in which they will
be organized and so fighting randomness
that is the cause of life and that fight
both requires energy but also
definitionally stores energy because an
organized state tends toward
disorganization the path down that hill
is one that releases energy and as that
energy is released it can be captured
and if it can be captured by another
organism it can be exploited and so we
have our second system living organisms
use to stay alive they don't make their
food they eat it
single-celled eukaryotes also called
protozoans dine on autotrophs digesting
their organic compound
to supplement their own bodies with the
nutrients and energy they need to grow
and survive and from their nature weaves
the complexity of the food web
transferring nutrients and energy
through this network of organisms
consuming other organisms
Berta's Owens eat protozoans and
sometimes even a few metazoans the
microscopic multicellular organisms like
rotifers water bears are fat flat worms
and then you get to metazoans that eat
protozoans like Daphnia which in turn
gets eaten by a fish the microscopic now
transitioning into the macro these
eaters consolidate the energy not just
keeping themselves alive but feeding the
more complex chemistry pushing
themselves further and further from
randomness further and further from the
equilibrium state but in the end no
matter what life neither big nor small
lasts eventually through random chance
or wear-and-tear the chemical systems
maintaining this far from equilibrium
state break and the living chemistry
ends and so we have our final
opportunity for energy transfer the last
link in the stored energy chain the
decomposers as microbes and plants and
animals alike die they decompose into
the environment their bodies broken down
and recycled by organisms like this
parinama which is usually found among
decaying organic matter here you can see
its mouth called the rod organ through
which it takes in bits of decomposing
matter and sometimes just other
organisms and eats them converting them
into carbohydrates that it stores in
those shiny para milan grain
though these decomposers come at the end
of the food chain well after the
sunlight that started at all they are
still surviving on that stored energy
originally flung out from two atoms
fusing in the core of the Sun and of
course the role they play in our
ecosystems is still vital as they break
down once living organisms into their
chemical building blocks they released
those nutrients back into the
environment ensuring that those building
blocks are available to the autotrophs
that will begin the cycle all over again
as we delve into more and more
ecosystems the vast number of factors
that have shaped the microbes evolution
become more and more apparent but one
thing remains consistent the chain of
stored energy the primary producers the
eaters and the decomposers sustaining
the chemical system that keeps them
complex the energy that holds them
together and that is holding you
together right now preventing you from
simply falling into randomness thank you
for coming on this journey with us as we
explore the unseen world that surrounds
us and thank you also to all of these
wonderful people for supporting this
channel on patreon making it possible
for us to do this if you want to see
more from our master of microscopes
James Weiss check out Jam and germs on
Instagram and if you want to sign up to
see more from journey to the micro
cosmos
there's probably a subscribe button
nearby and you can always find us at
youtube.com slash micro cosmos
[Music]